I think what's happening today is that
every Union is going to reflect the
views of their members and unite members
have voted to reject the offer that's on
the table
um and that's what we're going to be
sharing with the staff Council today
why do you think that is
I I can't speak for other unions but
what I do know about our members is that
they're really angry still about the
level of pay that they've been offered
um they're really sad that they've come
to this place where they're still having
to take strike action where they've had
to reject that offer they're exhausted
at how they're trying to keep the NHS
being propped up uh shifts are getting
dangerous
um the work they're being asked to do is
more and more but they're really
determined to carry on with that fight
when was the last time uh you or the
United Union spoke to the health
secretary
um I think that the last time was in
those conversations around
um the pay offer where he was in the
room but there haven't been any
conversation since then and we really
hope that the government can reopen
those negotiations
um the views of other NHS unions as well
as ours will be seen today but I think
it's safe to say that nobody is jumping
up and down and saying what a great deal
this is for NHS workers it is way below
inflation uh inflation is going to carry
on remaining High throughout this year
and NHS staff need better than what is
effectively a car in their cost of
living
um in the meantime strike action is
um continuing and for the first time
some critical care services not staffed
um is that sort of action going to
continue
each Union takes a view about what
action it takes
um unite has got action going across a
number of trusts in England today
including some ambulance trust and we'll
always have conversations with those
trusts directly about what that means
and how safety measures can be put in
place to protect the public but
ultimately this is Strike action in
order to have an effect
um industrial action has to be you know
it has to
stop services but we don't want to put
the public in danger
it's 50 50 really isn't it now amongst
your members looking at the latest
figures you may you may correct me on
that 48 voting in favor of accepting
um a deal 52 against
um it does look as though support from
your members is waning for continued
strike action
um I wouldn't say that what I would say
is that members are very angry still
they do want a resolution to this
situation there's no two ways about it
that vote reflects that that people
really want this to end but it will only
end when the government come up with
something that is
um really reflects the contribution of
those NHS workers
um to our country
you say that but we're hearing from the
General Secretary of the Royal College
of nurses there saying that strikes
could go on until Christmas do you think
that that potentially could be the case
with the unite members uh I think that's
potentially the case but as I say you
don't just want to take strike action
for the sake of taking strike action all
of us are in the place where we want
this ended members do not want to be
standing on picket lines they do want to
be paid a decent amount of money for the
work they do and how they hold the NHS
up for all of us um it's only fair and
reasonable that we're going to be
fighting until we get that